we are at the go proud big gay party
goes by Andrew Breitbart and featuring
Sophie B Hawkins let's find out what
people are thinking about the gays
you're going to talk to me for 30
seconds we're going to yell at each
other yell at each other you can't just
say that gay rights is a movement that
belongs in one party and when you talk
about those issues that deal with our
lives on an individual level on a very
basic level there is no one party that
owns gay rights gay rights is something
that history will show was the
transcendent civil rights movement of
our generation what has been the
reaction of conservatives and you came
in contact fretful very respectful I
think that this historic event was
predated by last year's CPAC rejection
of Ryan sorbus I'd like to condemned
CPAC for bringing go pride to this event
and he was rounding ly booed by the
entire audience it was a phenomenal
moment I think that that was the entree
it is very special evening
I think libertarians underestimate the
growing tolerance of conservatives that
conservatives I think historically have
under eight
the vibrancy that libertarians bring
economic Liberty is compatible with one
thing tolerance we don't have to agree
with each other we're all part of a
movement that recognizes freedom I think
everyone has their principles and their
lives in the sand this is not where my
line is at all people don't have
legitimate debates about the definition
of marriage and adoption all that stuff
but I think it is absolute electoral
insanity to exclude a group of people
from your potential voting base that you
like want to vote for you it doesn't
make any sense well you know I have you
on video talking about gay rights behind
new order just so you're now who is the
hottest man in the conservative movement
Chris Christie no doubt you like a fad
don't you the size of the pardon the
amount of fun people are having is a
very good sign that conservatives are a
lot more accepting than they might be
portrayed in common media and culture
you came out to the coke rad party give
me an idea what you make about the
an important part of who we are as
Republicans we believe in individual
freedoms and we believe in the
individual we're not a party of
exclusion we should never be that so
this is an opportunity to say we are
very proud to be Republicans of all
stripes backgrounds experiences and I'm
damn proud to be here jörg am proud to
be with Co proud that's right
ultimately go crowds involvement here
has been pretty successful I think that
people have taken an overall positive
view of it and I think that the boycott
of it has been more or less a failure
really if you want to talk about
fractious Ness at CPAC I actually think
that's a lot more evident when you look
at some of the Ron Paul supporters
versus some of the people who are bigger
fans of Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney it was
the young Ron Paul people shouting out
war criminal at Dick Cheney and then
some of them virtually being assaulted
by the traditional conservatives
usual spirited exercise
the gay issue has created nothing like
that so you're saying the bigger issue
was like neoconservative old guard
versus libertarian much bigger
overwhelming majority of Republicans are
accepting of conservatives who happen to
be gay into the fold I just I I won't
say that the the crazies within the
party don't exist they do exist three of
them are boycotting CPAC but look at
what's going on at CPAC there's an
overwhelming majority of people who
didn't boycott it and who are supportive
and look at the packed house tonight
there's a lot of very high-profile
Republicans who are supportive of you
know John Bolton for instance you know
people want to paint him into a corner
of being ultra conservative and he's
very supportive on gay issues would he
come out you think he would come out and
say that I've supported gay issues here
if he already has you want to asked
about Don't Ask Don't Tell or gay
marriage imagine what it's like being a
gay conservative other gay people are
really pressuring them or really
antagonizing them you see this all the
time saying how can you be gay in a
Republican those Republicans hate you
they want to take your rights away from
you so it takes so much courage to be a
gay person and to stand up and say I
know I'm going to get attacked but the
fact is this is what I believe and I
love this country and I love our troops
and I believe in the fundamental values
of a sound economic policy that the
conservatives and Republicans embrace
we're sort of limited government free
markets socially very liberal basically
what everyone should be it's perfect for
you you should be a libertarian you're
known as you're a Hillary Clinton
supporter you notice a liberal are you
getting any pushback but I have people
specifically been calling you a salir de
Trader etc sellout traitor you're
playing for the enemy and I said listen
no American is an enemy to me why don't
you stop judging what their um
superficial qualities are and who they
are on the social scheme and start
looking at people's souls you don't like
the identity politics of it right it's
killing us my neighbor you know has a
gun I'm excited because then he'll
protect me when I'm being robbed or
raped why should I worry that I don't
have a gun you should get a gun actually
I do have a gun yeah and I've been in
training because I live in a
neighborhood where the woman two doors
down was raped you know and I have a son
I have to protect my son
hey you have all the same people Bush
did why did you bother criticizing Bush
then the big bailout the first bill
another big disappointment we should be
drilling for the oil on our shores
getting rich then go green it's Sophie B
Hawkins you are a libertarian I'm just
I'm telling I'm not asking him now ditch
anybody and he said I'm doing that
conservative in the head
Oh